[Musique]
bon ben voila je vous laisse visiter
c'est pas mal c'est vrai sauf e trou
sinon bah ouais ouais ouais enfin
changer on peut changer la déco ah oui
bien sûr le problème mais trouve où les
way tu vois c'est bien pour enlever le
monsieur pendule de la pièce fire pour
qu'on voulait faire sa ba non pas parce
que c'est un monsieur quant à lui du
salon on ne peut pas vraiment pas
l'enlever
non je suis désolé elle est la
propriétaire était très stricte à ce
sujet en touche ni aux messieurs pendu
de la salle principale ni aux mini frigo
la kitchenette johanne frigon
je ne m'implique où tous ses chaussures
effectivement au moment du décès les
cinqueterre se relâche alors du coup ça
fait une espèce de petite flaque en
dessous mais vous savez c'est du lino
alors linde ou pas ce coup de circuit
mais au risque de paraître un poil
brutal il ya un autre couple qui est
prêt à signer dès demain matin voilà non
mais écoutez alors on va pas le prendre
parce que je pense qu'il n'a pas su
aller au droit out est une très très
belle affaire messieurs bravo bon ben
voilà bât blesse un petit peu un petit
peu visité il ya que ça qui nous
chagrine un petit peu en fait
ricane
[Musique]